[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce magazine football depuis le 30
avril le fc versailles 78 est assuré de
monter en national 3e division française
une grande première pour le club auteur
également d'un magnifique parcours en
coupe de france cette saison nous
recevons des membres du club pour parler
de cette fin de saison et de l année
prochaine rugby après avoir perdu le
match aller contre issoudun le mlsgp a
réussi une très belle roman tad à
domicile pour se qualifier en seizièmes
de finale de fédérale 3 l'équipe peut
toujours croire à une montée en fin de
saison plus d'informations à suivre
tennis de table une compétition
internationale handisport était
organisée la semaine dernière au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines des centaines de sportifs se
sont affrontées à l'occasion de ce
rendez vous qualificatif pour les
championnats du monde ce sera notre
module la découverte c'est parti à pour
l'actualité à sportive de la semaine
avant de développer ces titres on va
parler à d'aviron on ne le reverra plus
jeunes dans les bassins l'yvelinois
thomas baruch 34 ans a annoncé sa
retraite sportive après plusieurs
blessures contractées ces dernières
années le pensionnaire du cercle
nautique de versailles a notamment
brillé à l'occasion des jeux olympiques
de rio en 2016 en remportant une très
belle médaille de bronze en quatre sans
barreur poids léger il annoncé sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'il retiendra les
belles rencontres les moments
extraordinaires et les beaux résultats
et surtout un accomplissement un
personnel on continue à part du football
tombeur de saint malo le 30 avril
dernier le fc versailles 78 est promu en
national la troisième division française
une grande première pour le club auteur
également d'un magnifique parcours en
coupe de france cette saison pour nous
parler de cet objectif réalisé nous
avons avec nous en visio l'entraîneur de
l'équipe youssef chebbi et wilfrid
allergie à bonsoir messieurs
soir bonsoir alors une réaction tout
simplement suite à cette montée youssef
peut-être
la fierté avant tout le sentiment du
devoir accompli parce que ce fut une
saison longue riche intense en émotions
et c'est vrai que réussir à finir chan a
fini en tout cas a réussi à monter en
national à trois journées de la fin
c'est une vraie satisfaction il mérite
en revient principalement aux joueurs
wilfrid alédji même même réaction
de satisfaction
pensez pas qu'on s'est fixés en début de
saison
mais la joie est ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est un véritable soulagement c'était
l'objectif qui a été fixé en début de
saison il est accompli c'est un
soulagement oui c'est un soulagement
parce que
parce que la coupe de france nous a
aussi pompé beaucoup d'énergie
on a vu un avion cette épée damoclès
au-dessus de la tête ou le parcours
pouvait parfois prendre le pas sur le
championnat mais les gars ont fait
preuve de beaucoup de maturité de
concentration pour revenir encore plus
forts de nos rencontres de coupe de
france et tour est injectée en
championnat et on a vu qu'on a eu très
peu de baisse de régime cette saison et
ils essaient de régularité est à saluer
wilfred aladji comment vous l'avez fêté
dans le vestiaire cette messe est monté
voilà beaucoup d'émotion de la joie
quand même la mesure on aurait vu qu'on
est à l'extérieur on était sur les
terres de saint malo
donc du coup j'espère qu'on pourra fêter
avec notre public et ses adversaires
prochainement alors un mot sur chartres
aussi qui vous a amené un peu la vie
dure jusqu'au bout ils sont aujourd'hui
à 12 points
c'était quand même un adversaire coriace
ans quand même dans cette course à la
montée
oui chartres c'est une équipe qui fait
figure chaque saison de favori à
l'accession
sur les 3 de la saison c'est une équipe
qui a toujours fini dans les trois
premiers donc ça sera certainement le
cas encore cette année on le savait
avant de démarrer cette saison dont on a
pu tirer des jouer un peu les pronostics
parce que personne nous attendait mais
on tient également à saluer la qualité
de leur effectif et leur entraîneur
qu'est-ce qui a fait la force de ce
groupe versailles et tout au long de la
saison wilfrid alédji
c'est la cohésion c'est l'état d'esprit
principalement et aussi beaucoup de
travail c'est un couple gay qui est
vraiment à charles et travail c'est
vraiment une bonne bande de copains une
bonne demande de travailleurs et ça ça
réussit à fait à larciano sens fait ce
qui se passait dans mon vestiaire sur le
terrain et c'était un groupe nouveau
quand même youssef chebbi cette année ça
n'a pas été compliqué justement pour que
la mayonnaise prenne
bah c'est vrai qu'on a renouvelé
l'effectif à hauteur de 70% l'été
dernier
il a fallu faire une bonne préparation
bien chargé on a pu faire quelques
stages présent permis de renforcer les
liens et d'essayer de se découvrir
encore plus c'était important mais mais
l'état d'esprit de chaque joueur est à
saluer parce que sans la volonté commune
de faire un pas vers l'autre on aurait
beaucoup parmi beaucoup plus de temps à
se découvrir à s'apprécier à se
comprendre et on l'aurait pas trouvé
aussi rapidement sur le terrain donc
c'est vraiment à la base
les caractères de chaque homme qui ont
fait que ces deux réussites soit celle
ci aujourd'hui vous n'avez perdu qu'un
seul match cette saison en championnat
est ce qu'on peut vous dire que vous
êtes l'équipe l'une des équipes les plus
solides finalement du championnat
bat les statistiques parlent d'elles
mêmes à savoir qu'on est aujourd'hui
on est la meilleure défense de france de
quatre poules confondues
l'équipe tels moins perdu également donc
forcément se dégage une solidité une
envie commune de concéder le moindre
site la moindre situation défavorable et
ça ça c'est le reflet d'un langage
commun qu'on retrouve sur le terrain et
encore une fois la base c'est vraiment
les connexions entre chaque homme et
chaque joueur qui ont fait que qu'on a
cédé réussi d'aujourd'hui alors cette
année vous avez aussi vécu ce fabuleux
parcours en coupe de france vous êtes
allés jusqu'au stade des demi finales
vous avez perdu face à nice 2-0
finalement vous n'avez pas été humiliés
dans ce match à vous avez vous avez su
répondre à cette équipe de nice qui
terminera sûrement dans le top 5 de
ligue 1 est ce qu'on peut dire wilfrid
alédji que c'est une année de rêve
vraiment cette cette montée +77 coupe de
france je pense que c'est une année
dresse une année exceptionnelle il ya
très peu de gens pensent que julien a
parcours de coupe de france aussi aussi
longtemps avec une performance en
championnat régulière que tout au long
de la saison avec un aboutissement
qu'on l'a connue qui est la montée donc
c'est vraiment pour moi je
personnellement je n'ai pas connu deux
descentes comme ça et je pense que très
peu de joueurs amateurs peut se targuer
aujourd'hui d'avoir un parcours de
france telle qu'on l'a fait cumul à une
montée la veille saison c'est vraiment
serré youssef chebbi est ce que vous
l'aviez imaginé avant le début du
championnat ce ce parcours en coupe de
france combiné à 7 à cette montée
non ce serait présomptueux de le penser
c'est moi je me concentre principalement
sur le travail effectué sur le fait
d'essayer de fédérer de rassembler
autour d'un projet sportif concret se
retrouver sur le terrain mais mais les
c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui arrive à ce résultat là
notamment la coupe de france où il ya
quand même pas mal d'indécision
nom pouvait pas l'imaginer ne peux pas
l'imaginer honnêtement maintenant il
faut assurer ce titre de champion il
reste trois matches c'est un réel
objectif ou vous dit-on leurs vacances
c'est bon la sueur et les objectifs
dont des pas en vacances on à ce titre à
aller chercher face à une bonne équipe
de plabennec qui joue son maintien qui
nous a aussi donné du fil à retordre sur
le match aller et il ya aussi le
championnat il faut rester mesuré par
rapport à l'éthique du championnat donc
on laissera rien le des statistiques
aussi un 10-1 d'yvel et collectives à
aller chercher donc on a pas mal de
challenge qui nous permettra de rester
focus jusqu'à la fin du championnat
maintenant c'est quoi la suite pour
versailles pour pour la saison prochaine
et ce qu'il va y avoir un chamboulement
à l'intersaison où vous allez continuer
avec les mêmes joueurs
comme chaque intersaison forcément
l'avantagé qu'on a cette année c'est que
le seuil est de monter trois jours avant
la fin nous permettrait paraît un peu
plus tôt les contours de la saison
prochaine mais comme chaque intersaison
on va y aura des départs et des arrivées
donc on va pas échapper à la règle
oui il faut des ledjit est ce que vous
serez à versailles la saison prochaine
ah ça je sais pas si je peux garantir
mais en tout cas sans on entre en
avant-plan dans les entretiens
actuellement la ville en vue reste va se
passer là fonctionnement
l'objectif ça sera de se maintenir avant
tout youssef chibi à la saison prochaine
le championnat de nature est très
difficile en nationale 1 encore plus la
saison prochaine avec six descentes
puisque à une refonte des championnats
on
va y aller avec nos armes avec notre
volonté d'exister de ne pas arriver en
victime mais arrivait aussi avec
beaucoup d'humilité
respecter des équipes mais mais sur le
terrain mettre toute l'énergie qui nous
caractérise alors l'année prochaine il
ya une problématique c'est ce stade
d'hambourg on sait pas encore si vous
allez pouvoir jouer dans ce stade mob
rond est-ce que vous avez des certitudes
là dessus et youssef chebbi ou par
lasser en course et encourt aujourd'hui
la direction travaille dans ce sens
puisqu'on a plusieurs sites sur lesquels
on s'est positionné ça avance bien
maintenant on va communiquer
prochainement et le distrait de soins la
direction de de diffuser les
informations mais il est bien évidemment
qu'on s'est battus sur le terrain pour
pouvoir arriver à ce résultat et l'an
prochain en moi certainement un site qui
pour nous accueillir avant l'arrivée de
l'éclairage au stade de bronze je
l'espère aux dernières questions elle
concerne le nouveau logo un du club qui
vient tout juste de changer ce sera ma
dernière question qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de ce nouveau logo
wilfrid
je trouve qu'on retrouve les versets on
trouve les troubles et les symboles de
la lutte de versailles
on a la flore dans le soleil aujourd'hui
je suis pas spécialiste en
design
évolue c'est vous qui est au club depuis
longtemps
oui bah c'est c'est la modernité on va
dire même dans une ville historique
on nettoie un peu la poussière pour
essayer de d'avancer vers de nouveaux
objectifs et de nouveaux horizons et
c'est vrai que ce logo traduit traduit
tout cela en même temps
merci à vous d'être intervenu dans cette
émission je rappelle la date de votre
prochain match est peut-être le match du
titre de nationale 2 ce sera le 14 mai à
18 heures au stade mob auront contre
plabennec merci à tous les deux merci
alors on va maintenant parler rugby le
mlsgp eu chaud mais le mls gps se
qualifie pour les 1 16e de finale de
fédérale 3 les yvelinois sont venus à
bout d'issoudun ce dimanche le 8 mai
après avoir perdu le match aller à 15 à
13 le résumé de cette remonte à da des
images de senna à 400 go les joueurs du
hem et l'egypte et peuvent laisser
éclater leur joie après deux matches
accrochés face à issoudun ils sont
arrivés à remonter leurs deux points de
retard dans ce 32e de finale pourtant ce
dimanche lui mais rien n'a été simple
malgré une bonne première période le
score n'est que de 18 à 13 à la pause et
le spectre d'une élimination est encore
présent première mi-temps bien en place
mais dominer n'est pas gagner on a deux
temps forts on doit être meilleur pour
concrétiser les points
on est un peu dans le dur la 20e 22e
minute on n'arrive pas à concrétiser nos
temps forts des temps forts et non
concrétisées qui aurait pu coûter cher
dans cette seconde période issoudun
passe devant les immuno à quelques
minutes de la fin du match sur cette
action mais les joueurs de frédéric
jardin réagissent et réussissent à
marquer un nouvel essai score final 26 à
23 le mls gpu chaud mais se qualifie
pour les seizièmes de finale très très
très près et restait un gros match avec
une très belle équipe d'issoudun et
voilà c'était très dur jusqu'à la fin du
match et puis on a bien réussi à passer
devant et à se qualifier pour les
seizièmes 13 euros ce truc c'est ma
première phase finale en seniors du coup
très dur de vivre ça avec le groupe et
on va tout faire pour aller plus loin
possible au prochain tour le club
yvelinois affrontera l'équipe du ris y
sommes basés dans les départements du
puy-de-dôme un match attendu depuis le
début de la saison par le mlsgp c'était
l'objectif du club c'était d'arriver se
propage de monter pour pouvoir va
espérer monter si on rate le coche on
aura une deuxième lame même si je
préfère passer par la porte la plus
courts c'est-à-dire le premier match qui
nous attend la semaine prochaine pour
essayer justement d'inverser la pression
sur le premier match et qu'il retourne à
faire ce qu'il faut pour monter
directement le match aller programmé ce
dimanche 15 mai l'extérieur à leur tour
sera organisé dans le 78 le 22 mai
prochain on continue à parler de la
fédérale 3 vers ça joue également sur
son terrain en 32e de finale et les
versailles se sont brillamment imposés à
domicile sur le score de 31 12 contre
les sables d'olonne leur deuxième
victoire face à cet adversaire les
joueurs de la cité royale joueront
contre servian boujan 16e de finale une
équipe basée dans le département de
l'hérault en basket mauvaise opération
pour les féminines du chesnay versailles
en phase finale les héninois se sont
inclinés 56 à 42 sur le terrain de
bordeaux ambitions girondines résultats
qui placent le lcv en quatrième position
sur quatre dans la poule la prochaine
rencontre est programmée ce samedi 14
mai à 20 heures les féminines
affronteront bordeaux mais cette fois ci
à domicile
en football dans le championnat de r2
c'est terminé pour ouïe les yvelinois ne
monteront pas ils ont perdu chez eux et
dans le même temps bobigny a gagné 4 à 2
face à vallière crown de son côté
neauphle a concédé le match nul à
domicile face à franconville où il va
donc terminer deuxième eynaud devrait
terminer à la 10e place sur 12 toujours
en football un étage en dessous en
régionale 3 mauvaise opération pour
maurepas qui chutent sur le terrain des
ulis ce dimanche 9 mai dans le même
temps l'équipe 2 de versailles s'est
largement imposé face opérée sur le
score de 5 à 1 les deux équipes
yvelinoise devrait terminer dans le top
5 du classement en fin de saison on va
maintenant à parler de la conférence
ligue de football un événement a joué la
semaine dernière en demi finale de la
compétition
son nom à matteo guendouzi le joueur
originaire de poissy formé au psg
affronter le feyernoor de rotterdam ce
jeudi 5 mai titulaire il n'a pas réussi
à marquer pour qualifier l'om en finale
score final 0 à 0 au vélodrome après le
score de 3 à 2 au match aller matteo
guendouzi a maintenant pour objectif de
qualifier l'om en ligue des champions
athétisme à présent ce samedi à sète
mais la 8e édition des golden blocks et
passer par la place du marché à
guyancourt une grande première ronde
pour les yvelines concept réalisé un
sprint de 50 m en face à face sans
chrono ce dispositif a été lancé par
ladji doucouré champion du monde
d'athlétisme pour soutenir les quartiers
populaires on les écoute il était au
micro dé matile de front les dix villes
c'est un grand département on sait que
ça que ça département très sportif qui
qui donne beaucoup de possibilités aux
sports et l'éducation par le sport est
on est on est pareils on envie d'éduquer
les gamins au score on cherche des
talents on ait cherché à faire la
promotion donc pourquoi pas s'associer
sur certaines journées et les
accompagner à devenir des grands hommes
et des ventes femme tout simplement en
boxe bonne nouvelle pour l'illinois à
tony yoka il a été désigné pour disputer
le titre européen des lourds laissé
vacant le sportif originaires de
chanteloup les vignes va affronter
l'allemand agite cabaye est un boxeur
qui n'a jamais perdu et qui affiche un
bilan de 21 victoires dont 13 par ko la
date n'a pas encore été communiquée par
les organisateurs
mais avant de penser à ce combat tony
hawk affrontera le congo les martin
bacot l'est le 14 mai prochain à
l'accord arena à paris à la verrière les
curieux ont pu tester le à doha lundi à
dernier un sport d'un nouveau genre qui
allie à la fois le jeu vidéo et la balle
au prisonnier le concept deux équipes
s'affrontent à l'aide de boules
d'énergie de boucliers ce rendez vous
était le premier tournoi initiatives de
ce genre organisée dans les yvelines
l'écoutent l'un des organisateurs au
micro de justin ghazi chacun un viseur
en fait sur lui comme grande rose et on
peut construire des boucles
monographique comme un peu dans black
panther et on a des boules d'énergie
style kamehameha on doit viser un peu
comme si on jetait une boule de tennis
on doit viser en stratégie avec son
équipe l'équipe adverse et éviter
et les lébous d'énergie qui viennent
nous touchent et ados ça veut dire
vibration lorsqu'on voit des fois dans
les jeux vidéo à ado ken voilà est donc
en fait l'idée c'est de d'avoir
suffisamment bouclier on est limité de
gérer son énergie et avoir le plus de
mouvements possibles sur des matchs
cours comme le squash une minute trente
et on fait plusieurs matchs on va
maintenant parler d'un événement qui
fêtera le 16 mai prochain à ses 30 ans
le tiebreak roland garros fondée par
l'ivi noise véronique chaplin reviendra
lundi prochain golf robert à 100 à la
frontière du 78 le concept est toujours
le même des initiations sont organisées
sur un golf avec des enfants du
département en parallèle des sportifs de
haut niveau joueront au golf et enfin le
soir des enchères prestigieuse ouvertes
au public sont organisées c'est notre
interview express
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je démarré ma carrière doc chine ait jeu
j'avais la chance de rencontrer des
sportifs de haut niveau de très
nombreuses disciplines avec des
disciplines moins connu des grands
champions derrière et donc l'idée ça a
été de réunir sur un golf puisque le
golf est salutaire c'est une mise au
vert ça permet de se concentrer ça a
beaucoup de vertus notamment pour les
sportifs une rencontre golfique avec des
joueurs de roland garros des
footballeurs des rugbymans et des
athlètes et de disciplines très variées
et pour ce faire j'ai été voir le
directeur de roland garros et je lui ai
proposé ce service qu'il a accepté bien
volontiers puisqu'il nous a offert pour
démarrer cette aventure le label roland
garros et donc tous les ans pendant les
qualifs de roland garros ont fait cette
grande journée golfique où les sportifs
de haut niveau ont la joie de se
retrouver parce qu'il ya un vrai respect
d'une discipline à l'autre
on va se retrouver le lundi 16 mai sur
un golf avec la grande fête du sport
avec des ateliers des écoles des
yvelines le fc versailles une école de
judo une école de football et tous ces
jeunes vont être encadrés par des
médaillés olympiques et des champions
deux disciplines différentes
[Musique]
le clos c'est en fin d'après midi où il
ya une vente aux enchères qui est 100%
caritatives on a des très beaux objets
mythiques qui sont tous signés et
authentifié donc une vente aux enchères
avec beaucoup de bonne humeur beaucoup
de générosité et 100 % des dons sont
reversés pour le projet des jeunes cette
année on a la chance d'avoir la raquette
signé de djokovic et son blouson lacoste
qui l'a offert suite au tournoi de
monaco on a également le maillot de néma
on a un maillot de l'équipe de france de
foot on a un maillot du stade français
signé par l'ensemble des joueurs de
rugby on a une grande box d'hassan n'dam
champion du monde et quelques belles
bouteilles collector il ya d'autres
maillons qui vont arriver puisque j'ai
rendez vous là elle le club de rennes va
gentiment me remettre un maillot signé
de l'ensemble des joueurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va maintenant passer à notre module
sport à tournoi international de tennis
de table handisport était organisée la
semaine dernière pendant trois jours au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines un événement qui a réuni des
têtes d'affiché bixente mérian
scientiste et bals étaient sur place
regardez le sky par att french open
c'est un tournoi handisport de grande
ampleur il se déroule cette année pour
sa deuxième édition vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines du 5 au 8
mai plus de 300 projets s'ils vont
s'affronter pour des places
qualificatives au championnat du monde
nous allons suivre la première journée
de l'événement c'est parti
[Musique]
voilà
oui
[Applaudissements]
pour présenter un peu le tournoi on avec
geoffrey nisand habituellement tu es
directeur sportif au scalping
aujourd'hui organisateurs ça fait quoi
de changer un peu de rôles à c'est
totalement différent normalement je suis
derrière les joueurs et le coach
j'entraîne là je les vois pas les
joueurs je suis plutôt sur
l'organisation et et faire en sorte que
tous les pôles du tournoi se passe bien
voilà cette organisation-là ces quatre
jours intenses comment ça a été pensé
comment ça a été fait ici
du coup on a eu le premier tournoi en
novembre dernier qui on a mis un an pour
préparer sauf que pour passer sur un
coefficient 40 donc les plus gros
tournois internationaux on nous a
demandé de le faire en six mois
forcément un peu plus compliqué un peu
plus de travail mais le plus dur c'est
le début c'est pas les quatre jours de
compétition une fois que la compétition
est lancée c'est bon le futur c'est
toute la préparation
pour gérer tout ce qui va être transport
hébergement la salle respecter toutes
les normes etc pour la première édition
ça s'est déroulé à voisins le bretonneux
là c'est une enceinte un peu plus grande
ça change quoi
déjà ça change qu'on peut avoir un peu
plus de public donc on était limité à
500 personnes sur sur vos seins
bretonneux là on peut monter jusqu'à
5000 même si pour l'instant on n'a
ouvert que 1000 places puisque on ne
savait pas comment c'était et surtout ça
nous permet d'être serein lieu sites
olympiques ce qui était très important
pour nous puisque l'objectif est de
postuler sur le tournoi de qualification
olympique et paralympique l'année
prochaine et
aussi c'est pour avoir la place du
nombre de tables demandé pour le cahier
des charges l'année dernière on était
sûr
une salle de douze tables on doit être
sociale de 16 à 20 tables donc il nous
fallait une salle plus grande par
rapport à toutes les tables où tu disais
il ya sur les quatre jours de
compétition
d'abord c'est les championnats
seul et 1,13 par équipes c'est ça
comment ça se passe les quatre jours oui
alors c'est les simples les deux
premiers jours par contre les par équipe
n'existe plus l'année dernière on a aidé
par équipes mais il ya une nouvelle
formule pour les jeux qui a amené les
double double dames double messieurs et
double mixte donc on est le troisième
tournoi cette année elle est testée donc
c'est encore en rodage au niveau de la
fédération internationale mais l'idée
c'est qu'on soit prêt pour les jeux de
paris ont peut-être un petit mot pour
les les pongistes du scalping
merci à eux sont tous parce que il a
fallu beaucoup de monde pour organiser
heureusement cette année on était aussi
en co organisation avec la fédération
handisport ce qui nous a permis de
mutualiser de faire des binômes
bénévoles du club et salariés de la ffhg
franchement c'est top ça a super bien
marché donc merci aussi à tous merci
beaucoup geoffrey lisant ce tournoi vous
l'aurez compris c'est un rendez vous
international et qui dit rendez vous
international dit équipe de france
écoutez les réactions de la manager et
de fabien lamiraux multiple champion
olympique il ya 2 2 tournois cruciaux
dans la saison lascaux la semaine
prochaine donc en slovénie et l'open de
france qui sont vraiment les deux plus
gros tournoi de l'année et il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de points les chercher
c'est un système de ranking comme au
tennis pour qu'ils aillent se qualifier
notre objectif c'est à chaque tournoi
est dans le top 3 mondial des nations
jusqu'au jude pareil une belle enceinte
c'est une belle enceinte condé court
énormément dessiner un autre sport que
d'autres mais on s'en accommode ça fait
une belle ça une belle aire de jeu
plutôt conviviale avec des basses et une
balance entre une belle enceinte ou
alors on va ce qu'approuve s'apprivoiser
tranquillement et parmi les français
présents ici plusieurs viennent
forcément du club local le scalping nous
avons rencontré deux d'entre lucie et
youri pour nous parler de leur premier
jour de la compétition je suis donc avec
lucie du scalping l'uci est ce que tu me
parle un peu de l'ambiance ici comment
ça se passe pour les jours oui bien sûr
alors moi j'ai pas encore commencé je
parle deuxièmes de poule e
donc je commence à 14h30 je suis arrivé
un peu plus tôt pour supporter les tous
les français et puis je vais manger
assez tôt et
je vais commencer à mettre dans ma
routine a pris l'année dernière le
tournoi c'était à voisins le bretonneux
la c1 au vélodrome nationale naissance
un peu plus grand ça fait quoi de jouer
ici
les espaces de jeux sont plus grande je
trouve et c'est un coup être 40 donc en
fait c'est un plus gros tournoi essais
qualificatifs pour les mondes justement
qu'est-ce que tu vises toi tes objectifs
pendant ces quatre jours
gagner le plus possible de points et
et voir après parce que j'enchaîne en
fait je fais deux tournois aller en dix
jours j'enchaîne saint quentin en
yvelines et j'enchaîne lascaux en
slovénie donc faut aussi avoir des temps
de pause pour pouvoir accumuler toute la
fatigue qui aura pendant les dix jours
et pouvoir bien jouer aussi donc voilà
écoutons va suivre un peu bon courage
pour ce genre de compétition
[Musique]
je suis donc avec un autre joueur du
scalping yorick bonjour comment ça se
passe début du tournoi ce que tu as déjà
joué toi je viens de faire mon premier
match et il est perdu
jacques rocher alors j'ai joué le 7
mondial donc pas plutôt favoris de mec
les premiers de poule et je perds je
perds 3 1 donc je prends un set quand
même je fait douter mais j'ai pas su
je pas su être rigoureux dans la
tactique et le fait que ce soit le
premier match aussi j'ai pas pu jouer
mon meilleur jeu et en temps ils
expérimentent et les devants donc pas de
regrets j'ai fait je pas fait un mauvais
match je suis pas content de moi parce
que j'ai perdu mais au fond de moi je
dis faut quand même rester un content de
moi maintenant je raconte encore comment
quand ça va se passer là la suite la
compétition il tresse des matchs
aujourd'hui et quels sont tes objectifs
alors là on est sur les matchs de poules
donc moins dans mon objectif étant donné
que suit 58 mondiale à l'heure actuelle
un objectif c'est simplement de sortir
de poule parce que là il ya les 20
premiers mondiaux et bon bah je suis un
peu je suis loin de la liste mr de quel
objectif c'est de gagner des matches si
c'est possible de sortir de paul donc
gagner au moins les deux prochains
matches pour sortir des poules oies
qu'est ce que tu penses de l'ambiance
ici du tournoi un petit rapidement c'est
super franchement l'organisation un
super bien super le staff est super et
honnêtement il ya du monde et
franchement étonnamment
c'est kiffant corps de voir tous ces
gens toute cette exaltation tour et tous
les non c'est un petit stress une petite
adrénaline supplémentaire de voir les
collègues aussi jouer et c'est très
agréable by claude merci au rhic bon
courage pour la suite de la compétition
merci à toi au total 33 pays
représentant les cinq continents ont
participé à la compétition pour plus
d'un millier de match
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
oh